flanked by Chinese allies Nicaragua's
president Daniel Ortega mocked
International Critics on the eve of the
fifth anniversary of a failed National
Uprising to demand his resignation
now they are inventing that there are
more political prisoners so I tell those
governments along with the United States
to send me the list of the so-called
prisoners and we will send them off to
you
in February order data sent 222
political prisoners to the United States
stripping them of their property and
their citizenship
prisoners attended an anniversary mass
in Miami this week
but he's afraid he's afraid of our boys
he is afraid of our ideas and the only
thing that she was able to do because he
actually wanted us to kill us
the only thing that he could do is is
stripping us from our nationality
declare us non-citizen which is a
measure that is second only to to death
This is actually civil death
Ortega is now offering to send more
political prisoners whom he calls
terrorists into Exile several of them
are Catholic priests including a bishop
sentenced to 26 years in prison but who
is refusing to leave
although Ortega is a Catholic he
suspended ties with the Vatican last
month when Pope Francis referred to him
as a dictator
even nuns belonging to the order of
Mother Teresa of Calcutta have been
expelled and More Than 3 100 ngos have
been shut down
tens of thousands of nicaraguans have
also fled the country
this fifth anniversary brings a first
memories but also a commitment to
continue for this struggle to liberate
once and for all Nicaragua and bring
democracy back but Ortega appears
confident that he can remain in power as
he prepares to receive another powerful
Ally Russia's foreign minister Sergey
lavrov who's scheduled to arrive in
Managua later this week
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera